welcome to the waste talk at PI data
we're going to be telling you a lot
about the evolution of Python data and
research in ways over the years and
let's start by introducing ourselves I
think so
my name is segi and this is CP and we've
been working together for the past five
years or so I think so I actually
started working in ways about eight or
nine years ago something like that and
about five years ago I interviewed CP
and we've been working together ever
since
so we've exchanged a few teams over the
years as we survived the fewer yours I
think and we've worked on a range of
stuff from data infrastructure to
parking features and all kinds of stuff
and today we're both part of the routing
and ETA team part of the ways back-end
development so that's us
so we'll be telling you sort of walking
you through sort of the evolution of
data and researcher ways through the
years sort of just to give away the
ending this is sort of it ends with our
love story with Jupiter or more
accurately with the combination of
Jupiter and PI spark and pandas and
plotly and all of these packages bundled
up together so that is sort of the
ending now let's see how we got there so
yeah so served Eugenia what we'll talk
about you know MapReduce and spark and
some turning points along the way and
schemas or schema-less and yeah all
sorts of stuff we'll just go through
that okay so I want to start and back in
2009 when I 2009 when I started working
for waste and so back then this is sort
of the way I was doing research when I
started so we were using a tool called
qgs which probably most of you have
never even heard about and this is the
tool I was using it's pretty nice tool
that sort of allows you to do
geographical visualizations of data it's
sort of like but
a player's on top of GPS points and no
kinds of geometries and just visualize
them one on top of the other so it's
pretty much stolen by pretty nice I mean
this was a god-awful horrible way to
work it was really awful not so much
maybe because the tool was awful the
tool was well you could have improved
that it was nice but really the way we
were working was really really not
interactive and we'll see that evolved
over the years but basically you have to
we wrote our Java code and the Java code
outputted whatever we wanted to
visualized and you had to create a jar
you had to upload it to some server that
had access to all the other servers and
databases and everything then that
server outputted what you wanted to
visualize into a file or into a post
ghost database and then you had to
configure it all and qgs to have it load
everything and only then you saw your
your data visualized and it was such a
long feedback loop that it was really
cumbersome and hard to do and took like
from hours to minutes a day sometimes so
this was really this was an awful way to
work but you know it we got stuff done I
mean we did risk research with it and we
got stuff done so it kind of worked and
whenever we needed to plot stuff I guess
we just used like spreadsheets or
whatever common software we had
available so if you move forward like a
year or two this is when structured data
started to appear in way sort of so
before this basically all the data was
just unstructured log prints like the
servers were just printing stuff into
logs just whatever they wanted to print
exceptions and I don't know descriptions
and stuff just free text and and people
would look at that and around this time
is when structured data started to
appear and was mainly mostly CSV at the
time so servers started to up with their
data and structured CSV with fields and
everything but the data never came with
a schema so like if you wanted to
actually process the data or figure out
what was going on you have to look at
the code of the server or or and just or
try to figure out yourself and sort of
figure out okay column five is like
dane and column six as that field and
whatever so yeah you had to do all this
work manually okay looking another year
or two forward this is sort of when we
started to use so the data the volume of
data in ways was starting to really grow
and grow massively and started to us out
scale us and so this is around the time
that we started using actual big data in
ways and this started I was using
MapReduce in Java to actually process
the data so we started moving processes
to use MapReduce in Java stuff like
taking all the speed measurements and
averaging them and having like a speed
average for every road segment in
different hours of the day in different
days of the week these sort of mass
processing that we had to get done to
get ta for example and stuff like that
we started moving that into my produce
and around the same time the analytics
department started working with hi I
don't know if you guys know hive hive is
sort of like this SQL language that
basically operates MapReduce behind the
scenes and they started using hi which
basically meant they were running
MapReduce over all of the structured
data that I mentioned before as I said
none of this stuff came with a schema so
they the analytics department basically
started maintaining manually maintaining
their own schemas of everything in order
to be able to run queries on it and
research so against things started to
grow massively and as things started to
grow massively even simple things like
grapping logs for exceptions or trying
to debug something started being really
out scale or not practical to do I mean
developers used to just you know
download their log and grep it did to
figure out what was going on this start
became really non practical as as we got
it into massive growth so to solve that
this is around this time we also develop
well we internally call the iam our grep
software it's not much of a software
really but it's basically sort of this
script and this is really
it looked like or still looks like it's
a scrape that called that's called the
EMR grip that sort of lets you say okay
you say your Mar grab you say the path
of where your logs are in s3 you can use
a star-like to get all the logs from all
of your different servers and then you
just put the string and you sort of grep
it as if it was a you know just a normal
grep command but really what happens is
the script SS ages do this cluster
that's always up and running this
cluster has you know clustering at AWS
and this cluster always has Hadoop
MapReduce and everything installed on it
and it just runs MapReduce on all of
your logs grep sets sort of a grep
reduce kind of program and just gives
you back the the lines and the logs that
match your whatever your grepping so all
developers basically started to use
MapReduce even if the worm really aware
of it most of the time and and actually
I think it's still predominantly used to
this day right I mean yeah so it's it's
starting to get less and less as people
get to know Jupiter and stuff will get
to later by a thing it's still mostly
used by developers whenever they want to
just get something from their logs or
their unstructured data just to get that
line back okay more evolutions that
happened
that's Dragonite more evolutions that
happen is so with visualization if you
remember cue gist I talked about before
so I guess I was around 2013 I know we
kind of manually guessed some of the
dates here but it's hard to date that
but I think it was around 2013 that we
got sort of got sick of using qgs so we
moved to trying to visualize stuff over
our ways map editor ways map editor is
just it's a website anyone can access
and waste calm okay it's just lets you
edit the map or have suggestions for
edits so we had this sort of internal
version of the same website that we just
had Java strip on top off to let us
visualize data and play with it on top
of it this was a big step forward in
terms of
researching data and playing with it
because you could just stuff you could
never doing huges you could like you can
click on you could click on a segment
and then display just the data that's
relevant to that segment like roads just
data relevant to that road then you
could click on another road that data
disappears new data just relevant to
that road appears you can like there was
interaction going on stuff that we're
never going on we were working with qgs
with that said it was still you know it
was still very a lot of stuff were
difficult to use because you still had
to write like a MapReduce code to get
all of your data to bring ovie data
process it into something that this
layer could read and uploaded yesthey
and only then you could like use this
javascript player to actually play with
the data and look at it this was step
forward in visualization we move another
e forward I think so
more data formats started to appear in
ways more structured data mainly stuff
like protobuf started to appear so
servers are trying to we're starting to
use protobuf as their structured data
instead of CSVs
and if you thought CSVs were sort of
hard to query with you know MapReduce
really high for whatever you're doing
proto's are pretty much impossible and
you can you can I mean you can start
right start trying to write plug-ins for
it and stuff to make it work with hive
but it's really difficult and it's hard
to get to work we try doing that for a
while and also we started using a
Cassandra databases doctors Postgres
just sort of non SQL databases and
probably some of you are familiar with
dos
Cassandra databases also you know
difficult to work with in the sense that
they're great for online servers but if
you want to start querying that data and
you know joining it with other data from
structured data that your servers are
outputting it's it's pretty hard it's
not really easy to do but basically what
we managed to do eventually and you know
we is not asked specifically but other
people is just have this process written
with MapReduce that takes all the files
from the Cassandra nodes themselves from
the database nodes it's basically SST
Abel's fliers of you guys are familiar
with it and just run a MapReduce process
on that and I'll put everything in a CSV
or some structured format that you can
now run you know your querying on it so
this is the process that was developed
some time later after we started using
Cassandra and this is still used to this
day I think basically so the CSV zarnow
parkade we'll talk about that later and
the MapReduce is now SPARC but this
process still is still up and running
this is the way we we used to query
Cassandra data offline and join it with
the rest of our data right so we're
moving another year or two forward we
started moving for a MapReduce to SPARC
so I think in 2015-16 probably SPARC was
already there for a while I don't think
we're that early adopters at all but
this is around the time that we got
around to using it and we just started
writing new things in SPARC instead of
MapReduce and slowly converting old
MapReduce tough to spark I think today
like probably 90% of our NOC pipelines
are now SPARC and just a few legacy ones
are still in MapReduce okay so now we
reach sort of a turning point in our
story and this is where the ways beacons
project sort of joins up with our story
ways because I think started actually in
2016 kind of and not 2017 but it joins
our story 2017 so just to explain what
the ways beacons is if maybe some of you
are familiar we were basically trying to
solve this problem of navigating in a
tunnel or someplace where you don't have
any GPS reception so and the main thing
to accomplish was to be able to give you
instructions when you reach a turning
point in the tunnel right turn right or
turn left in this intersection even
though the center section is like has no
GPS reception it's Underground we still
want to be able to give you that
instruction on time so that you make the
right turn this was a big problem before
we had the solution and this is what the
project was trying to solve and the way
it solved that is basically we install
these ways beacons that's like
realize one think that you took that
picture for my desk what you do oh it's
not mine no no but my beacon okay
I think she's stole my beacon okay so so
that's a real bit that's what it looks
like you basically take that and just
tape it on top of the tunnel
every so-and-so meters and it's just a
it's sort of a Bluetooth transmitter and
then your your phone or yeah oh the app
picks up the booth booth signals from
these transmitters and just pinpoint
your location using using that Bluetooth
data that's the beacons project and
where'd this joins I story is that what
we were trying to accomplish is just to
have this sort of algorithm that would
pinpoint that we would receive that like
vendors install of these beacons by
themselves not having to start to
coordinate stuff with us and then trying
to develop an algorithm and then on our
side we just pick up all the Bluetooth
signals for people passing through these
beacons and try to figure out ourselves
like which beacon ID is installed where
in the tunnel and in what order okay
this is sort of the project we were
trying to accomplish and where all this
joins our story say yeah want to
continue okay so and here comes one of
our favorite team members favorites
mother his name is Daniel today is
working in Zurich in a Google but like a
few months ago he moved but he he he
moved to our team from the web
development team and he came with the
old front-end knowledge and all the you
know being organized and doing stuff you
know fit you know like really really
well so when he got this project he was
like how am I supposed to do like you
you expect me to write some Java code
put it somewhere then somehow get the
output and put it on on top of the ways
map and every time I want to fix like
some bug have to do this all over again
it's like this you know it's
like he wanted like a really short
feedback loop for testing his ideas so
lucky for us he's really inventive and
very knowledgeable in you know
everything related to content so we
researched what is going on of you know
what is popular right now and he came up
with
I found that Jupiter non-book could be a
really good solution for for the
research purposes and he managed to he
basically managed to set up a notebook
on his laptop with all the necessary
access to all the databases etcetera as
free locations and everything he needed
for his for his research and he
basically managed to write PI SPARC code
which is spark within Python and use the
output to display geographic information
on top of folio map which is if you know
phoneme it's a Python library that
envelopes
I think leaflet it's a Java Script other
library and basically it displays the
geographic information on top of Open
Street Map so and also of course used
plotly for graphs so we were like wow
who mind blown
did you do this this is amazing we
didn't use it before like maybe some of
us you know sometimes use it for doing
something really really simple but we
didn't know it was possible to do all
these amazing things with with this open
source tool so of course everyone were
super Angus and because you can see what
in managed you know you compare that
with the stuff we did before I want to
share a person I know that when enjoying
ways my one of my first tasks was
getting that JavaScript code used as a
Chrome extension which was for me like a
big step in found that because that was
the first thing I did it for intend and
was like wow I was so following said
that I managed to do it and then he come
up comes up with this this is insane so
so we always really wanted to work with
it as well and so the worm segi
suggested that Danny will find a
solution for it to be a central point of
access that everyone can use like
everyone in our team at first and and so
everyone could use it
researching it and really like it took
like I think maybe two months or
something like that for it to be up and
running and for almost all all of our
team using it which was really super
cool I imagined that we used Jupiter hub
which is it's a sister project of
Jupiter which basically used for for
saying setting up a mains server for
like academic research like if you if
people want to have like that's how they
publicize it on the website like they I
don't think they specifically mentioned
what we are doing with it but maybe
maybe they did so it so that was really
lucky for us that it became so popular
at the same time so um and now the plot
thickens will actually show a live
demonstration of the Jupiter in just a
few slides logistic are sort of complete
the picture they were going through time
here so this is really a project that we
we did this year this is really fresh
stuff or really we've reached 2018
pretty much this is a project we called
the grade wolf schema and its birth
purpose was started to close things
around if you remember I said everything
up to now the structured data did not
have a schema with it people start
people kept maintaining everything
manually and the main purpose of this
project was just to get all the
structured data coming out with a schema
automatically built into it and on the
way we also solved all these problems
with you know protobufs and all these
other structured data that were not
easily available and the solution was
basically to transfer everything into
Park it so the servers were still
running as normal and you know using
protobuf sees fees whatever they're
using before but we had jobs in place
that could transfer everything into Park
it right right as they were out put it
and then our kid is easily credible by
SPARC definitely easily usable in PI
SPARC and Jupiter or whatever you want
and it has a schema built into it into
the files so this was the great wall of
schema right
purpose was to get over these schemas
automatically with everything and all
the data query in a credible format but
okay right so just you're just at the
end of that project to close everything
up is when we added the Waze data
library inside Jupiter which is what
we'll show you in a second and basically
the purpose of this library was now that
all this data is available in parkade
with a schema with everything just to
make it all super easy to use with
completions everything inside Jupiter
and and the way goals you'll show you in
a minute you can just you hit ways data
dot and then you get a list of sory like
tab you get a list of servers you can
hit dot again like on a server you get
tab you get the list of you know all the
structure types of data you have that
server dot load for some date and then
you can start working with the data
immediately so that was sort of the ways
that data packaged and we now all use
okay so now it's a live demonstration
alright so yeah so today basically
everyone new ways or anyone with the
proper permissions can just hit go ways
go slash ways Jupiter and they get
immediate access to the way stupider
notebooks and we've prepared one in
advance I guess just to show you what
it's like sit so this is like an actual
notebook okay and you so just to
demonstrate this okay so say I want to
now access our map okay so I do ways
that data you get all kinds of data here
okay so I know the map is saved in a
puskás database so it's phosphorus you
can have you know you have Cassandra
here or yeah well you have offenses like
structured just log data and you can ask
us any of those so we hit park post rest
now we have all the types of servers
that have Posterous we have two
databases still using puskás that's live
in users so live is basically the the
server that holds the map itself yes
and then there's only segments you're
segments
basically all the parts of that your
keeper is not set up for you okay
that segments and everything has
completions and now let's just run this
okay yes the latest snapshot of the map
in Israel I guess right yeah okay okay
and afterwards what we're gonna do is
just query all the segments that have
over three kilometers yeah
3,000 meters or two and take the first
500 of those I'll just run that and
after that we also have the ways our map
library we can visually stuff over the
Waze map so we create a map of you know
connecting to the Israeli map and then
we add the layer of all those segments
that we just quit
yes this is this Python code so it's
with that wait we're getting to the end
okay okay
I love the fonts nope I'm sorry oops too
much okay